>> Laura: MATT, THANK YOU,
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> THE TOP DOMESTIC VIOLENT
EXTREMIST THREAT COMES FROM
RACIALLY OR ETHNICALLY MOTIVATED
VIOLENT EXTREMISTS, SPECIFICALLY
THOSE WHO ADVOCATE FOR THE
SUPERIORITY OF THE WHITE RACE.
>> WE FACE AN ELEVATED THREAT
FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMIST.
I DECIDED TO ESTABLISH A
DOMESTIC TERRORISM UNIT TO
AUGMENT OUR EXISTING APPROACH.
>> Laura: THAT BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT, HE NEEDED TO SHOW
SOME RESULTS OF ALL THAT
DOMESTIC EXTREMISM, RIGHT?
ACCORDING TO JIM JORDAN, WELL,
THE RESULTS WERE NOT HONEST.
THE TOPPER REPUBLICAN ON THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TOLD
FOX DIGITAL THAT NEW
WHISTLE-BLOWER DOCUMENTS ALLEGE
THAT THE FBI IS PRESSURING TO
RECLASSIFY CASES AS DOMESTIC
VIOLENT EXTREMISM THAT ARE NOT
EXAMPLES OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMISM AND JORDAN ALLEGES
THIS IS BEING DONE IN ORDER TO
JUSTIFY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S PUSH TO FOCUS
ON THESE CASES AND HAVE A
SPECIAL UNIT FOCUSING ON THEM.
HERE NOW IS GLENN GREENWALD,
WHOSE WORK I READ ON SUB STACK.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF
THESE DOMESTIC VIOLENT EXTREMISM
CASES, BUT I GUESS THEY'RE GOING
TO FIND SOME.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
SURPRISING, LAURA, EVEN THOUGH
THEY NOW CITE JANUARY 6TH IS THE
REASON THEY HAVE TO INCREASE
THEIR ATTENTION TO THIS PROBLEM,
IN FACT EVEN BEFORE JANUARY 6TH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WAS
SAYING ONE OF ITS KEY PRIORITIES
WAS TO IMPORT THE WAR ON TERROR
ONTO DOMESTIC SOIL AND MAKE THAT
BE A NEW WAR ON TERROR, ONLY
THIS TIME AIMED AT AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND THROUGHOUT 2021,
THERE WERE SO MANY INSTANCES
WHERE DHS, HOMELAND SECURITY
ISSUE ONE MORNING AFTER THE
NEXT, THIS GOING TO BE AN ATTACK
ON THE INAUGURATION, THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ONE FROM COVID, ONE
FROM A TULSA MASSACRE MEMORIAL.
YOU CAN SEE THEM EXAGGERATING
AND INFLATING A THREAT THE
ENTIRE TIME BECAUSE WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO IS USHER IN ALL SORTS
OF AUTHORITARIAN ATTACKS ON
CIVIL LIBERTIES IN THE NAME OF
THIS DOMESTIC WAR ON TERROR
SINCE THEY DON'T HAVE THE CASES.
NOW THEY ARE JUST MAKING THEM
UP.
WHICH IS, BY THE WAY, WHAT THEY
DID DURING THE FIRST WAR ON
TERROR AS WELL.
>> Laura: WELL, I WAS
MENTIONING THIS MATT WHITAKER IN
THE PREVIOUS SEGMENT, BUT WHEN
YOU THINK OF THE CONCERN THAT IS
RAISED WITH GENTLY, OBVIOUSLY
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN POUNDS AND
RELENTLESSLY PERSECUTES HIS
POLITICAL CRITICS, YOU START TO
SEE THAT OUR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING -- AND
THIS IS JUST ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF
IT -- BECOMES WHAT THEY ARE
WAVING HER ARMS AROUND ABOUT.
THEY APPEAR TO BE HOUNDING AND
PROSECUTING AND SURVEILLING
THEIR POLITICAL CRITICS.
>> YOU KNOW, WE'VE OBTAINED, AND
I'VE DONE REPORTING ON, THE
DOCUMENTS FROM HOMELAND SECURITY
WHERE THEY IDENTIFY THE KINDS OF
PEOPLE THEY REGARD AS QUOTE
UNQUOTE "DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS."
AND USUALLY IT'S JUST PEOPLE
WITH ANTIESTABLISHMENT POLITICS.
THEY WILL SAY PEOPLE WHO ARE
AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT, WHO
QUESTION THE LEGITIMACY OF
GOVERNMENT AUTHORITY.
EVEN THERE ARE SOMETIMES PEOPLE
AND LEFT, THEY WILL SAY ANIMAL
RIGHTS ACTIVISTS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVISTS AND
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT WHO ARE
PRO-LIFE ACTIVISTS, IT'S CLEARLY
AIMED AT ANY SORT OF EXERCISE OF
FREE SPEECH AND FREE ASSOCIATION
AND FREE POLITICAL PROTESTING OF
THE CONSTITUTION IS SUPPOSED TO
GUARANTEE, THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO SAY -- OR JUST EXTREMISTS AND
NOW SHOULD BE REGARDED AS
TERRORISM.
>> Laura: THERE'S A FEELING
OF -- AMONG MANY POLITICAL
OBSERVERS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
SQUEALING OVER DEMOCRACY IS ON
THE EDGE, NICE EDGE.
NONE OF THAT IS ACTUALLY
GENUINE, GIVEN THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE PROPPING UP ALL THESE
SUPPOSEDLY FAR RIGHT CANDIDATES.
THE DCC CHAIR WAS ASKED ABOUT
THIS.
WATCH.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO THE FAR
RIGHT CANDIDATES, ARE YOU
ACTIVELY DOING ANYTHING TO HELP
CANDIDATES THAT YOU THINK MIGHT
BE EASIER TO ABATE IN NOVEMBER?
>> IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO PICK YOUR OPPONENT,
YOU MIGHT SEE US DO THAT, SURE.
AND I THINK SOMETIMES IT DOES
MAKE SENSE.
LARGELY WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
TELLING VOTERS A FACT THAT IF
THEY ARE AWARE OF, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM, I THINK YOU
MIGHT SEE US DO THAT, SURE.
>> Laura: IS DEMOCRACY AT RISK
OR NOT?
>> YOU WOULD THINK IF THE
DEMOCRATS REALLY BELIEVE WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING, WHICH IS THAT
TRUMP ALIGNED CANDIDATES ARE NOT
WHAT'S A PREMISE IS SPENT ON
ENDING DEMOCRACY AND INSTALLING
A WHITE NATIONALIST
DICTATORSHIP, THE PROBABLY
WOULDN'T BE SUPPORTING THOSE
CANDIDATES, AND IT IS SO FUNNY
TO WATCH NUMBERS OF THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE WITH LIZ
CHENEY AND ADAM KINZINGER
OUTRAGED BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY
APPARENTLY BELIEVE THE DEMOCRATS
AND THEY ARE SAYING WAIT, WE
THOUGHT YOU REALLY BELIEVE THAT
THESE CANDIDATES WERE FRIENDS OF
DEMOCRACY, WHY ARE YOU
SUPPORTING THEM AGAINST
ANTI-TRUMP REPUBLICANS LIKE
PETER MEASURE, 1 OF 10
REPUBLICANS TO VOTE FOR TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT?
THEY APPARENTLY TOOK THE
DEMOCRATS SERIOUSLY AND NOW ARE
REALIZING THE THING W